pourquoi la justice d'un côté a-t-elle
décidé de relâcher deux membres
d'extrême droite qui revendiquent leur
appartenance à un mouvement nazi qui
crie partout dehors les immigrés àat les
Juifs et de garder en prison six jeunes
immigrés qui sont de de parents
originair d'Afrique du
Nord je voudrais bien qu'on revienne à
l'objet direct de cette émission qui
était d'évoqué le racisme à l'occasion
de la semaine et les manifestation de de
samedi dernier pendant longtemps vous le
savez les Français ont eu la réputation
de ne pas être raciste une réputation
qui pour beaucoup est maintenant
d'ailleurs largement usurpée alors
est-ce la crise économique ou bien
est-ce l'augmentation du nombre des
immigrés dans certains secteurs en tout
cas on entend maintenant souvent parler
d'immigrés attaqués de ratonnad de
rumeurs déclenchant l'inquiétude et le
racisme dans certains villages ou dans
certaines villes c'est un enchaînement
que Dominique Torz d'ailleurs a retrouvé
à Bondi bondi c'est en scène saint n
près de Paris ces inscriptions racistes
sur les murs de Bondi ont été tracées il
y a moins de 10 jours par qui peut-être
par ce même groupe casqué armé de
matraque que se jeta le 30 mai dernier
sur des jeunes arabes qui discutaient
tranquillement dans le haall de leur
immeuble on a vu arriver une quinzaine
de de personnes crân rasé habillé en
training tout il débar dans les mains
des chaîn tout puis ils étaient vers 20
m de nous tout d'un coup ils ont crié à
mort les
Arabes la France Liv des trucs comme ça
puis nous dès qu'on a ça on a commencé à
courir bon moi j'ai cour comme les
autres puis il y a un copain à moi qui
est tombé puis moi je suis tombé sur lui
puis après bon je l'ai ramassé je l'ai
poussé puis moi j'ai pas pu partir ils
m'ont attrapé c'est là qu'ils ont
commencé à mettre des des coups de PO
des coups de bar de tout puis il y en a
un qui arrivé vers moi il a commencé à
déchil le
rasoir après il y a quelqu'un qui il y a
des gens qui commencent crier par les
fenêtres tout bon dès qu'ils ont vu ça
ils ont commencé à se calmer un peu puis
dès qu'ils ont vu une fille descendre en
courant tout vers moi là là ils sont ils
ont commencé à partir puis criéer la
même chose des trucs comme
ça maintenant tout le monde est
terrorisé ici la victime bien sûr qui a
d'ailleurs exigé l'anonymat mais aussi
tous ses camarades de la
cité et maintenant les gens ont peur ici
on a l'impression que personne ne veut
parler personne ne veut être filmé
surtout bah filmer non mais parler ouais
pourquoi vous avez peur vous avez peur
qu'il reviennne bah ouais de toute façon
ils vont il vont s revenir hein s
reviennent pas ici il reviennent d'autre
part vous avez l'intention de vous
défendre bah s' viennent ici ouais
et la police qu'est-ce qu'elle fait la
policeelle fait des rondes mais on a
l'impression que c'est contôle nous lieu
de contrôler les agresseurs on sent
plutôt agresseur que
agress à partir du drame lui bien réel
de Mohamed les rumeurs les plusugren
circulent notamment abord des écoles
c'est le r du on vu des fascistes d' des
Arab on parle de rap de que saisje
encore
vous venez souvent chercher votre niè
alors pourquoi maintenantv je viens
spécialement parce que ma sœur me l'a
demandé pour revenir chercher ses filles
à au lycée à cause qu'il y a des bandes
organisées qui soi-disant sont fascistes
maintenant je ne sais pas exactement si
c'est si c'est pour ça so soi-disant
entre les Arabes c'est surtout pour les
Arabes mais enfin on prend peur et hier
c'était la vraie panique les parents
étaient venus chercher les enfants à la
sortie du lycée tout ça j'avis pas
envoyé ma gamine hier après-midi à
l'école
C Rais par des jees hommes
Matra devantécole cach là dans le coin
ouiire alors j'ai pas enyé ma fille puis
ce matin je suis oigé de conduire et
vous madame moi j'ai pr jours moi pour
venir chercher ma fille ça sera pas à
l'école du tout du tout du tout abondi
la psycho s'amplifie malgré les appels
au calme de la municipalité c'est
peut-être parce que la police elle ne s
pas prendre très au sérieux cette
affaire pour le commissaire de police
cela n'est qu'une simple querelle de
loubar il commence à crier à Mor les
Arabes tout nous on a commencé à avoir
peur on a commencé à courir il un de mes
copains qui est tombé moi je suis tombé
sur lui j'ai pu le ramasser et le
pousser puis moi j'ai pas pu c'est là
qui m'ont attrapé bon ils ont commencé à
mettre des coups de PO des coups de
pieds des coups de bar tout puis il y en
a un qui est arrivé derrière moi il a
commencé déch
rasoir
[Musique]
selon vous qui sont ces ces garçons qui
ont débarqué un jour pour chercher la
bagarre à bondit pour moi c'est ce du
PFN les FAF quoi comment le savez-vous
parce que mon copain m'a celui qui a été
agassé m'a donné leur description et
tout comment ils étaient habillés et
tout ils ont crié à mort les Arabes mort
aux Arabes pour moi il y a pas de
problème et pourtant parmi vous n a pas
que des Arabes ouais mais on est
majorité plutôt la majorité on était ils
étaient cinq ils étaient quatre arabes
et un français on dit qu'à Chel il s'est
passé également des choses bizarres à
Chel c'est vrai parce qu'il y avait eu
des tractes et tout il y avait eu des
tractes de fé et tout et pour ça c'est
vrai qu'est-ce qui s'est passé je sais
pas entendu dire que ils étaient
descendus dans une école et ils avaient
attrapé des petits magrébiens de 89 ans
il les avait tapé ils avaient tapé je
sais plus ce qui je me rappelle plus ce
qu'ils l'uront fait mais je sais qu'il
avaent tap et vous croyez que c'est vrai
ouais ouais je crois que c'est
vrai je crois qu'on a profité
d'événements qui se sont produits à
Bondi mais qui malheureusement se
produisent dans d'autres villes du
département pour monter ce qui m paraaît
une vaste provocation c'est-à-dire que à
partir de fait réel on a tenté de créer
un climat de peur raciale dans toute une
ville et si nous n'avions pas pris au
départ des mesures d'apaisement nous
aurions pu avoir des véritables
catastrophes parce que de tous les côtés
les esprits se montaient la peur est
très mauvaise conseillère et finalement
un exalté un fou ou même le résultat
d'une méprise aurait pu nous conduire à
quoi à peut-être un mort vous vous en
souvenez peut-être à la fin du mois
d'avril dans la banlieue parisienne à
Bondi à henis sous bois des incidents
racistes avaient amené l'arrestation de
militants d'extrême droite et de
nord-africain dernièrement clauerillon
les militants d'extrême droite ont été
relâchés mais nord africain reste en
prison et sans doute pour l'été encore
oui c'est ça pour bien comprendre cette
histoire je crois qu'il faut se rappeler
qu'effectivement il y a une série
d'agressions d'attaques de provocations
d'inscription raciste dans sur sur
quelques murs à HN sous-bois où à Bondi
alors cette époque làà on avait un peu
pensé queil y avait un climat raciste on
l'avait nié d'un côté on avait renforcé
les effectifs de police et puis le 11
juin la police arrête deux membres de la
femme vous savez ce groupe d'extrême
droite qui notamment revendiquit les
attentats contre le MRAP à Paris alors
on les arrête quelques jours plus tard
on les juge en flagrant délit et euh
afin sans doute d'apaiser les esprits on
leur donne une condamnation de 4 mois
avec surc ils sont donc remis en liberté
or le lendemain le 12 au soir colère des
jeunes immigrés de la région d'oleny et
il partent en voiture en expédition
punitive avec des des barres de fer et
une arme un 635 que la police retrouve
lors de d'un contrôle c'est-à-dire qu'on
les on les contrôle on aurte une voiture
on trouve ces armesl alors on on a on
met en prison six jeunes dont deux
mineurs et ça se passe donc le 12 au
soir depuis ces jeunes sont toujours en
détention c'està-dire qu'on a maintenu
en détention juge d'instruction avait
avait dit non il est pas nécessaire de
les maintenir en détention on les a
quand même gardé en prison depuis le dou
depuis les deux mineurs ont eu 18 ans en
prison et la question l'on se posait ce
matin au cours d'une conférence de
presse d'un comité de soutien qui s'est
formé dans région d'olnais c'est
pourquoi une mesure discriminatoire
pourquoi la justice d'un côté a-t-elle
décidé de relâcher avec une condamnation
de 4 mois ex surc cert mais de relâcher
demand memb d'extrême droite qui
revendiqueent leur appartenance à un
mouvement nazi qui crie partout dehors
les immigrés abat les Juifs et de garder
en prison si jeunes immigrés qui sont de
de parents originair d'Afrique du Nord
alors cette misure discriminatoire est
quand même un petit peu inquiétant C
deux poids de mesure d'autant que ça
continue qu'il y a toujours des
inscriptions sur les murs et que
régulièrement il y a un processus de
provocation entre les les deux parties
c'està-dire immigrés et groupe d'extrême
droite alors ce matin j'ai interrogé un
jeune qui n'a pas voulu être filmé de
face il a 19 ans et c'est celui-là même
qui fut blessé de 54 coups de rasoir
qu'il porte encore il porte encore les
traces sur le dos ça se passait le 31
mai je vous propose de l'écouter vous
dire encore un fait qui s'est passé hier
encore abondi chose de 19 ans quand on
les a vu nous il é en train de coller
des affiches oui il y avait
marqué la France libre il marqué aussi
Hal à l'invasion ouais et marqué
l'œeuvre française et il vous pour
chasse il tent de vous attaquer bah oui
hein parce que dès qu'ils nous ont vu
ils ont couru vers leur voiture puis
puis je crois qu'ils nous ont couru
après parceils ont démarré d' façon
terrible ils sont armés bah oui armés
commentah ils avaient des ils avaient
des matraques tout gourdin et dans les
camionnettes on Savit pas ce qu'ils
avaient parce qu'ils ont couru vers leur
camionnettes c'est qu'ils avaient
quelque chose vous avez l'impression
qu'on qu'on ne réserve pas le même sort
voil ou aux uns et aux autres ouais
c'est ça pourquoi d'après vous que nous
déjà d nous on est étranger on est
étranger mais tandis que ils sont
français c'est ça qui qui joue aussi par
que nous attendent que ça pour nous
expulser ou pour nous enfermer ils
attendent que ça ils attendaient que ça
là ils sont contents
[Musique]
là